hi
i'm jesse i'm a software engineer
working
at an iq company specializing in
education
industry based in tokyo so my twitter
card
is jessie tatsuya so i'm all three
walking both data science and
engineering and i've been involved with
several data-driven projects and i've
been implementing them at apis and ml
ops
environment so prior to the current job
i used to study the relationships
between online learning behaviors and
online learning outcomes of higher
education in the uk
and before that i used to maintain and
develop
a learning management system used for
vocational skills and prep schools
so based on these experiences i'm gonna
try to talk about
transformation from research oriented
code into machine learning apis with
python
so the reason i'm going to talk about
these topics is because
recently python engineers have more
opportunities to work with
scientists and researchers than before
since understanding the processes to the
proper amount apis can help
make aiml projects work more smoothly
so the target audience might be
engineers who are working with data
scientists or researchers
or engineers who are involved with aimma
projects
or researchers and data scientists
involved in
aiming projects but this topic
seems to be very broad so the
developmental process can be different
depending on each situation of your
working place
so before getting down to the main topic
let me tell you the two premises in this
talk
so in this talk i used sample data and
the codes
for educational technologies so let me
share
what educational technologies are like
what data can be stored
and how they are used so there is one
major type of educational technologies
such as learning management system or
online
platform for example gsa moodle
blackboard udemy addicts kosura and
others
so these systems have several functions
to
have learners to study online for
example
online quiz function can be ever
fortunate to take online quizzes
by using the functions teachers can make
online tasks and
dispute them to students so video
function
can make it possible for students to
take lessons from home
through pc screen so while they are
using these functions
the learning loop data is stored in
database behind the learning management
system
so generally the characteristics of the
learning look data as time series format
so data include what students take
online tests what kind of online tested
disputed
when students online tasks and whether
they answer the quick
answers the quizzes or not and get
correct answers or not
[Music]
so by using learning log data data
scientists write
research oriented codes through finding
optimal ml models or algorithms
so engineers transformed the research
oriented code into mlpis
and integra integrated them into the
learning management system
or the online platform so this talk
works
on the processes of transformation from
research oriented code into mlapis
which is surrounded by gray bars on this
side
okay all right so now let's get down to
the main topic
so there are four steps to
transformation transform research
oriented code into mlrpis
so understand the research oriented code
uh marginalize it
refraction it and the reticle to check
how it can behave correctly
[Music]
so the first step is to understand the
research oriented code
so i'm going to answer these questions
what is the research oriented guide
what are meta apis and how should
engineers handle research oriented code
so i will use a fast in some people in
this song
so let's look at definition of research
oriented code
a research oriented child in aiml
projects
is occurred written mainly by data
scientists or researchers for figuring
out the most
efficient and suitable machine learning
model
so machine learning apis are composed of
three
elements preparation called
think about ml code or terrification
code so research is focusing more on
writing pre-processing called nmr code
or confusion code
through an iterative process and then it
is integrated
into production code on the other hand
engineers have responsibility to write
whole part of the account in production
level
so this is example of pre-processing
code written by
researchers these codes seem to be long
function
and useful root and this code can allow
researchers to visually
trace the code from the top to the
bottom and easily and quickly write that
so this is a sample m a code with
logistic regression
this code can not use dotapan and use
dataframe
but it can make researchers easily
handle input data and choice
output data waste data prime
so this code is example obviously
written by engineers
this code seems to be much shorter than
previous code and the less computation
it's a computation and there are two
simple functions at the bottom
actual discord can be the model in a
much faster and simpler way
so i identify three differences between
our research on detail and the
production code so
there are different scopes different
characteristics recording styles
and different objective recording styles
so research is focused more on writing
representing code and america
on the other hand engineers have a
responsibility to
write whole particularly in production
level
so the reset oriented codes need to be
easily handled
and the visually transfer on the other
hand the production code needs to be
concerned about high direction speed
high readability and they should be a
testable and
modular this is because the research is
focused on finding
the most efficient and suitable machine
learning model and on the other hand
engineers have responsibility to
make the code work on sabbah quickly and
reliably
so now what a python engineer is
supposed to do for research or rented
code
so modularize a researcher go into
preparation code focusing code and
americorps
and refactor them and write together to
check
how it can work quickly
so second step is to modularize the code
so there are three small steps uh first
of all
categorize the research or risk into
preparation code
preprocessing code and number code or
characteristic code
so if they can break them out into
functions and make them testable
and the last could modify important
output to the code and define
uri
[Music]
so this is a page of sample research
oriented code
written on jupiter notebook so this code
is written for calculating probabilities
to get
students correct answers for certain
questions of exams
this code is a procedure and some of
them are not classified
and it could be harder for us to
understand the role of each code
i actually wrote it but i started to
understand the code
so this is because this oriented
research this is
this research orientation seems to be
seem to be tightly coupled
so in order to categorize this code
particularly to load input data or
access database first
it can be categorized as preparation
value
so next principle to make a replace
filter or
delete input data it can be
pre-processing code
then find care to execute calculation or
train data it can be categorized as
a method
so i could categorize the research
oriented code into
preparation called preprocessor and my
code like the table on the slide
at the same time we could get modules
for each from one page
of research or instagram so
preparation.pie has functions to
access the equally executed query and
low input data in the rename columns
prepresent.file has functions to replace
categorical data with discrete numbers
and filter input data
prediction.pi has functions to calculate
parameters logistically regression
and item response theory item response
theory is also called as two parameters
logistical regression
this is just used for calculating
probabilities to get students quickly
answer
this statistical method is used mainly
in pedagogical domain
so yeah now we can see the research
oriented code it becomes really
happening
[Music]
so there is a table of input data on the
left side
which is used for two parameters
regression
on the right side there is a table of
output data calculated by the model
so the input data is about whether
students answer each
question correctly or not so their
item name which is the name of questions
item id
how difficult discretion is subject
names
are names and corrections binary data
on the other hand output data is about
probabilities to answer
questions uh quickly the really
the role of the api is to get
probabilities
so we can directly level probabilities
as an
important name so based on best
practices
function name should be verbal verb just
now
the rule of this function is to
calculate
results or get probability so we can
a level calculus result will get pops as
a function
so understanding what data is input and
output
which means understanding what it is the
code
uh characterizing makes is conceivably
important to
important step to make api
[Music]
so now we could get and create this
character
of the ml api modulized
from a page of research oriented
[Music]
so now we can move to uh refractive
devices
but we need to prepare for refactoring
first
and there are two main parts of
refactoring which is the io and part
scale
so let's look at these processes in more
detail
so i don't i did not include the
factoring of ml code this is because ml
code tends to be short
and also most of ml code is under code
is based on ml libraries so there might
not be spaces to be right or things
so yeah uh the preparation code and the
pre-processing code tend to be more
redundant than the repetitive
americans so big bo humat
means unstructured code unless we mexico
the more maintainable
the code to prepare any pre-processed
data will be the
big bowl of mat so during the proof of
concept which
shows the movement cycles for example
when rushing to
write code and develop model
and at the same time during visual
expressions we tend to create a big
format
with security of preparation and
pre-process
so we try to input certain kinds of data
and check out but
rather than we try to use several kinds
of algorithms
so after we finish to quickly write a
research already detailed
and look back to the code to prepare the
preprocess we can see
several groups of redundant
repetitive code so in this section i
will tell you the process to
create the redundant and the
levity code with sample code
so before starting to refactor we might
need to understand more about
count in order to narrow down the
requirements of
code write the test code and take note
about the requirements of each code
so there are objections which i
modularized in previous slides
the api directory has opted pi
uh which is any point to get
probabilities and copy 5 prediction
and configure a prediction to the pi and
prediction to try and prepare single
device
so the test directory has 4 modules of
test code 4h so when taking notes in
this code you can use sharp comment art
or dark swings
so there are four kinds of dark suits
such as a restructure star
numbers like yogurt and it is
slightly different but uh type hint
so you can choose one that you like and
i prefer to use the google style because
other styles say
parameters instead of arguments and i
feel more
a bit more comfortable for using
arguments instead of parameters
and on top of that type of hint can be
one of the options which some
you already come up with but uh yeah
actually any kind of message are okay to
take note
understanding the requirements of each
code is
most important most important here than
how to write documents
[Music]
so after we wrote test code and suit
more than 70 percent
or 80 percent of requirements of each
code we can start to refactor it
so i'm going to show you a case study
with a refractive indicator to access
equally and the gps
by using google cloud client libraries
with python
yeah there are two kinds of code on this
slide they call
a uses star and extract all data from
data set
and output two-dimensional arrays that
call b
has a role to extract three specific
kinds of data from a data set
only when column one is not now
so they quickly filter these values and
drop now
i suggest that you pre-process the data
with equally as much as possible if you
use
bigquery but this is because it is a
faster and lower cost
than the process data with pricing the
cost and the processing speed also
equally
is increased based on the model data
process
so when you're writing pre preparation
though to access gcs i suggest that you
manifest objects
and upload it from memory to gcs with
pricing
i tended to write the code to make sure
the price on local
load it and upload it from ctgs
this is because it allows me to quickly
write a code so as a result a larger
model sheets will probably sometimes
saying
logo and consume extra memory on pc
so i suggest that you make right object
however this code seems to be very long
so
[Music]
so i should simplify more by developing
or using wrapper library
there are two kinds of code with google
client
libraries which i showed in the previous
slides
so it combines and simplifies to
kinds of codes in so doing it reduces
the total amount of code so gcp access
is a package of dirt so after this talk
is finished
if you have an interesting name please
feel
free to contact us
[Music]
so now we can transform high coding
style with
part parameters into recording style
with python
in pre-processing code so all data
in the api should be processed using the
same data type
this import improves uh readability and
maintainability
as opposed to prioritizing coding speed
so one day i wondered why i struggled so
much with the function of the limited
code of pre-processing
in research oriented code that i watched
previous week
the reason is that there are
many kinds of coding sites
with partners as you can see on this
table
for example free to function has six
kinds of coding sites
and i think that there are more than i
wrote here
and in case according sideways on this a
python
it just uses basically least
comprehension each function
on top of that the different styles of
code responders tend to be read
really repetitive when trying to
pre-process data
in different ways so upon this is very
powerful
and useful for the wrong ring
but uh the code might decrease
readability
depending on each so situation way of
coding without partners could be easier
for
engineers to raise the code and it could
increase readability and maintainability
[Music]
so last step is to write code to check
if the code can work correctly
so there are two things to do write
decorators to check parameters and
setting up production-like environments
[Music]
so this is the image of decorators in
the apis
so after trying to send the request api
is checked
whether parameters is correct or not and
check access token
if something something wrong with the
card happens and the error handler will
cut error
if there are nothing wrong with the code
request will reach to
any point i don't have enough time to
describe
all of them so i'm going to focus on
talking about weakest parameter check
so i'm going to show an example of focus
parameter check with json schema
that is request card command has student
name and
student grades parameters this json file
is sample json schema
in this file you can define what they
should be checked and how the dealership
check
so this make name this make name great
dot
json file is defining the data type of
student
member string and it must be included as
a request parameters
and the data type of student grade is
also defined as string
and it must be included as two and the
maximum length
of characters is limited in 1-20
and a minimum length is one character so
in this example because parameters are
not allowed to be
empty so based on jason schema the json
you validate buy validates request
parameters
the first validation validation function
checks whether the adjacent schema is so
or not the second validate schema
function
checks whether the request parameters
are cracked or not based on json schema
defined in previous slide so in order to
execute
these functions write function name as a
syntax
trigger under the end point as i looked
over json validation code in the web uh
most of the code
like this on this side so you can easily
find a lot of
similar sample resources on the web
[Music]
yeah i'll finally set up production like
environment with france there are just
twos and this
um conference is about pricing
and data so i don't talk about how to
use them in tutorial
uh so i just show you options uh setup
visualization tools such as tableau
luca video studio which is a data
data portal uh redash
when trying to automate continuous
integrations github
services and podcast there might be
common options
as some of you already know after
setting up cia
environments you can deploy on gcp aws
is of course is okay so these might be
typical options for
ml apis as some of you might already
know
too so also you can monitor the response
speed of m apis and
check the response by implementing
system loans
and analysis logs in advance
it is useful for engineers um to find
the drift of modern
debacle so i suggest that you
look up class or python-based class
python-based frameworks such as first
computer
dash and logist the first ability
allows you to manage and visualize data
dash can make it possible to interactly
communicate with the data
a low caste is a test to
locate is a load of test2
which can also allows you to do scenario
tests
so these cloud services and tools
should be used depending on service
sites and phases
if you need to consider scaring you
might need to think about the pipeline
architectures
but i think that what i talked to this
talk is the
general and the common tips in any
phases
[Music]
uh there are already a lot of resources
about the tools on the web
and tutorials are already presented in
the past python around the world so you
can look over them by yourself
later i'm gonna i'm going to share this
slide on my twitter
so we have an interesting so you can
follow me so and
you can look over it later
so lastly yes uh last step ah no last
pound that's right so let me quickly uh
summarize
uh the four steps to transform research
originally
into an apis so first step is to
understand
what research original linear projects
looks like
and what components and apis are
required in your projects
and how to handle research or instagram
so next is to moisturize the research
orange scale
through three small steps um
this uh to categorize it into
preparation called
preprocess numerical or carication code
and break them out into functions
and make them testable and then glorify
and put an
output of each code and define uri
so thirdly it is reporting after
preparing for
refactoring i simplify io code in
preparation code
and change coding style responders into
python only
in three percent code so lastly
write write code to check how it can
work quickly
by implementing decorators and setting
up production-like
environments so that's all uh
yeah that's all thank you so much so if
you are interested in the education
technology domain or
refactoring mr apis yeah
feel free to contact with me so yeah
thank you so much